[Music]
in Cooper dependent news
Cooper intended Cooper Intendant Oh
submitted by Tyler says hi Gio
oh hi Tyler a mystery highschool pooper
was finally revealed to be the super
Intendant what do you mean he's been
[ __ ] all over the hallway no he's
like a upper person yeah what is the
superintendent superintendents like the
principal of the school school district
in Tendo is a game he's been drive-by
shootings no he's cleaning [ __ ] he
was doing in the whole mansion he's been
drive-by shitty that's what you've been
doing why maybe epilepsy that's why I
said he's been [ __ ] in the hallways
or where well apparently you [ __ ]
around the school property I'm not
really inside what's wrong with this
shed like employees at these guys funny
they were finding feces pretty much on a
daily basis if it's a big [ __ ] I'd be
like that's either an adult or a big kid
yeah I don't think I've seen him in a
Doberman around a lot of homeless people
you said right sure you mean [ __ ] when
you see it but [ __ ] looks different
it doesn't have any as many wrinkles as
humans do really yeah it's pretty smooth
sometimes sometimes dog human shits
looks like a little brain the brown
brain have you ever picked up dog [ __ ]
and humans hadn't thought of his dog
[ __ ] or no no they picks up the [ __ ]
that he sees our dogs smell Samaritan
just picking up brand of [ __ ] oh right
on
you know what I found out recently about
myself that if I care about the
neighborhood that I'm in I will stop
somebody from [ __ ] in front of me
Wow a person yes well aren't you just
damn Robin Hood I thought I was that's
exactly what I felt because I just
recently was like I like my neighborhood
and this dude was about to take a [ __ ]
like I don't do that Wow
because it's like it's a good
neighborhood there's kids around never
nicest place I was like hey what are you
doing man oh he was right next to a
public bathroom I was like what was his
excuse no I he didn't say anything you
just like crazy
Pierre and head feels like
headlights he was a soft-serve coming
out when you were looking at him pulling
his [ __ ] past I was like no bro like
it was kind of weird because there's a
public bathroom right there I was like I
would have waited while he was [ __ ]
and then as he's [ __ ] pushed him
down on his own [ __ ] yeah
just wait [ __ ] come on like that my like
you know and slam him down he's like oh
[ __ ] and then now he's got good [ __ ]
booty but it was like downtown LA I
would apologize to him I'm like I'm
sorry sir and I just walk by
right cuz that's history yeah exactly I
ain't rooted on his place I don't know
those homeless guys bikes oh yeah
sometimes you see people [ __ ]
outside and you're just like you know
what are you doing yeah I mean I guess
if you think if somebody looks like they
really need to [ __ ] then you know I'm
like if I can't survive like oh that
person has to share probably had to [ __ ]
one time probably yeah Bobby's [ __ ] at
the beach he's always [ __ ] on rocks
and stuff on YouTube you don't see it
there's a video log sprained it yeah
that is insane that's not even yeah why
do you have to do that like in what
place you and you got to do that wakes
up in the morning it just drinks
parasites yeah like his fingers he shits
like all those sites
yeah Kyle I taught him caught him peeing
on the balcony for like five or six
years same bucket oh wait why with the
bucket
he's two folks out there and like it's
too crazy
yeah that's so [ __ ] funny he makes
fun of like like Vietnamese people for
being like savages [ __ ] funny he's
spraying on walls with his bubble yeah
he would eat his own body if he caught
it and make him food before he went to
the kitchen he would eat his own body
that's a lazy is yeah that's the [ __ ]
love Bobby dinner you could have saw his
own body if you had like a sauce to dip
it oh my god he's a superintendent that
bollocks he looks like a serial killer
he'd suffered a penny
Brow's dude yeah oh he looks scary
so authorities set up surveillance on
music schools that were getting
defecated on yeah yeah so they finally
caught this fool and he got arrested at
5:30 in the morning near the football
field did he get off on it I don't know
there's three miles away from his home
so he could be like Christopher Walken's
unwanted son or something yes I mean yes
it looks like he could poop out of his
eyes even I think it's awesome the home
principal dude I'll [ __ ] around town
right your [ __ ] principal dude he's
above the principal yeah you can't [ __ ]
out of school than [ __ ] him I quit
you know after his arrest he requested
and was granted a paid leave a leave of
absence paid yeah is that even like can
you fire somebody for just shooting
around your school I don't think you can
everybody else is doing all kinds of bad
stuff at school people are shooting them
up this guy's just taking a [ __ ] it's
funny that's his argument - it's like
we're talking what the [ __ ] it's funny
how much time and effort he puts into
doing this [ __ ] cuz he has to wake up
[ __ ] early you know he has to scope
the spot like he has to plan it out just
to take a [ __ ] he's a hardcore Greek
yeah at different schools - so he's like
the [ __ ] bandit can you imagine like the
janitor finding [ __ ] and then like he
maybe goes to the janitor committee for
any letters love it yeah they're like do
they love punish it I think why because
that's the business they're in you can't
be like yeah you can't hate it but
that's what you you know I'm saying like
it's kind of like a detective that now
has to do some real [ __ ] like now they
have to find out a murder versus like
finding out like where the cat went
missing it's like the janitor takes his
job way too seriously he just finds the
school he goes two days ago yeah a lot
of janitors that that yeah I think a
real janitor probably is okay with it
stoked about finance [ __ ] outside yeah
he probably gets chalk and draw the
circle on it
it's evidence puts a little postcard and
[Laughter]
nobody get near mush is what has corn
dude how badass is that though as a kid
like you [ __ ] hate all the higher-ups
try to like you [ __ ] me most of your
teachers off and now you find out one of
them is [ __ ] you're like [ __ ] yeah I
wouldn't think it's cool no I think kids
think it's awesome you think they think
it's awesome I would call them [ __ ] man
I bet to like do mr. [ __ ] so-and-so
[ __ ] everywhere
mr. [ __ ] looks so evil he's upset
like it looks could kill bro he probably
hates children now he [ __ ] hates the
kids he also he looks like he loves the
kids at the same time oh I could see him
about in a ball gag and ask this test
yeah yeah he definitely seems Homer oh
what a [ __ ] spike collar looks like
what is a Super Nintendo do ya do the
principal of principal there above
Skinner like there yeah they're in
charger they're in charge of all the
principal's Intendant yeah dang man
that's awesome though dude I'm trying to
think we had this div this vice
principal mr. Coleman and they used to
catch him sleeping in his car at lunch
in the trunk dude he would get into the
trunk of his car Freud have a backseat
down and lay like that oh Jesus have it
tied off a little bit we're just to make
sure the air was still getting in and he
just be laying in there rest why does he
just sleep in his office some people get
upset probably damn this we all knew all
the kids were all [ __ ] around around
campus you know just this man Raleigh
Coleman would get over there he would
get in his Trump damn he must have had
like oh yeah his whole family slept a
lot that sucked a lot too is the sleepy
family maybe they just didn't get any
rest at the house yeah all anemic or
something dude dude I had a friend they
had a gas leak in his house for a long
time and we didn't know it and we go
over there to in his whole [ __ ]
feeling to be asleep we go over there
and go to sleep on Friday night wake up
on Sunday [ __ ] morning the whole
family bro who are you
walk in the kitchen and his mom would be
like making a salad
dad asleep dude family you walk in the
living room the whole family like
watching the smoker in that house nobody
figured it out they were just kind of
lazy and chill and like Louisiana pipes
do tell a story I hear a [ __ ] banjo
play behind just rest you know do we
sleep over there all weekend bro dad
asleep bro
we've you got insomnia just go to
homeboys house oh it felt so good didn't
you went over there and we that's all we
kept going over there is like you wake
up and feel nothing great it just
hibernated the whole weekend yeah
you don't just Mel that sulfur or
propane or whatever we didn't smell it
man
cuz they were always doing like his dad
ran a paint and company to something get
had like a lot hanging like like like
Christmas lights let's set the mood it's
just red [ __ ] felt markers
it's just dead Canaries everywhere coal
miner has to come in with a canary okay
this is not good his dad delivered mail
to his dad was a mailman and he had a
pain visit damn what a hustler yeah hard
workers
his mom taught children she was a Sunday
school teacher I'm just like you bro I
know but she was probably a lot better
at it she was really sweet but the only
day she was awake Sunday it was the one
day she was opposed to rest that she
didn't
she's like we're not making any money
since I Chi making the $35 a week
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]